hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba you
know my [ __ ] name now I'm John
Humphrey you probably don't know it as
well as his that's not true everyone
knows John we have a topper war chariot
or patreon this basically goes like this
if you request a video we must do it and
put up on YouTube so actually have to
coming at the end of this month that are
not reaction based which is so exciting
but we got a reaction that we're gonna
do right now to a man named Derek Jeter
gene Jeter here we've seen a couple of
his videos and this one is easily the
one I am most anticipating from the guy
okay I'm gonna give a couple of little
background things here the message he
sent me was here's the link a monologue
from 2013 I had trouble going to sleep
one day but then when I went to bed I
couldn't sleep because I had something
all right
which took under five minutes I got a
voiceover Todd sort of core but he
didn't want to be credited because of
the content which made me go this video
is called white privilege wouldn't you
if you were white twenty-two thousand
years which is pretty good for a channel
with 3.7 K followers it's a really good
numbers and 26 upvotes 36 downloads
which has got me like I'm very a very
intrigued to find out what this is I am
very comfortable to find out I'm half
white I got European me we did that DNA
test yeah but you got all of like the
olive places all the really pale spots
yeah man because that's where the crimes
from good probably you know what it's
the truth so I'm just gonna say I love
that I'm white sorry to say that but I
love that I'm white
excuse me I love that I'm Caucasian yes
I loved
why you know we all know why because of
white privilege white privilege is
incredible there is no other immunity on
the planet outside the human body that
can top it
I never have to worry about having my
items checked when I enter a train
station I never have to worry about
paying first for something to gain trust
I never have to prove what I said is
right yes it's correct
like it'll almost this pretty will be
unlimited I can get any job I want as
soon as they see my white face but most
times I got the job as soon as they read
my name on the resume sometimes I use
this privilege power to [ __ ] with people
I came up to these black high school
teenagers around their school and I said
it was a detective show me some ID I
showed so much [ __ ] they were
nervous they thought they were going to
jail or I'd contact their parents so
funny
what were they nervous about another
time I saw a big line for me for some
currently popular non-singing urban
harvest inside the mall and I told
people up front that we were going to
start the line outside the mall once the
first people started moving all of the
default conformity is another amazing
power and what saw this young Latino
photographer passing out flyers in the
street to promote his work nobody was
really taking him seriously it was
pathetic
so I thought hmm I wonder if I could get
some women to accept me as a
photographer even though no well I just
came up to these two hot young ladies
and said hey I'm a photographer I don't
have any more business cards or my
portfolio money but I'm the real deal
you don't have to work I gave them my
phone number and they gave me theirs
hits totally sweet I bought a cheap
camera take some okay pictures and
eventually [ __ ] both of them at the same
time white people
exactly at the same time you know what
and that's another thing I never have to
worry about getting any kind of the
woman I want the smart women know the
color of our eyes in the
of our hair with our People magazine
faces will be acceptable no matter where
we go everybody
I didn't choose to be one as far as
money is concerned we have money we look
like if I don't have any I can totally
dress and act like I have money and
nobody will ever think otherwise most
times just look clean or on occasion
wear a jacket and a tie I'm good I like
to wear my leather jacket or my
motorcycle jacket I'm good that way as
well doesn't take much when you're what
I can [ __ ] about anything to see I
have a master's degree a made-up subject
lots of times I don't have to [ __ ]
about it people just assume I'm smart
and must have connections just because
I'm white I must be able to answer this
question or help out just because I know
what's easy power question this power
Trump's puss and white privilege it is
never going away either the minority
will soon become the majority yes I know
unfortunately but we will still have
privilege over hey it's just the way it
is in like a No Limit credit card I am
just gonna enjoy all the benefits I can
wouldn't you you were what I deserve
that
yeah for being born this way you're
doing I chose this brought this on
yourself I was like oh clearly that's
the easiest okay I'll give me that one
option what yeah so why would you choose
any horror you mean institutional in
case you guys don't know Jean pure white
the Whitest Kids u know why it is dude
you'll ever mean hmm actually think Jean
is it it's a black man black I mean
black and I'm just gonna let you do it
black thank your anchorman oh yeah yeah
that excellent sequence more famous than
the first one
know why I can't stop saying black the
word black we're living an interesting
time to listen to a Joe Rogan podcast
jrt powerful time he was talking about
you know see things on social media
about like you know don't date white
people why people this by people that
while there is a thing out there of
white privilege
I don't think all white people are bad
people he said no we all just born with
an original sin in a you know a societal
kind of problems well that's better for
that we each need to choose to you know
baptize ourselves you know try to walk
that straight and narrow
some people do abuse this power and
whatever but at the same time I say
statement like what I'm about to say
people will say well don't feel that way
people will there's a part of me think
it's like a little concern for certain
white people you know it's the time now
where people are really taking a stand
on things and a big thing that's
happening is you know the attacking of
like white privilege right you know you
don't talking about right I do get a
little bit on the weary side about it
because it's unavoidable at this point
it's gonna become a political video now
everything about this what's your
perspective on it on white privilege
video yeah what he's talking about here
I mean it was an interesting change of
pace you know coming from Jean because
this is you know definitely a different
kind of video I mean yeah I thought it
was a nice monologue in general I liked
your voice actor and whatnot and and
yeah I mean I've never thought from this
perspective and it's an interesting one
to hear from because it is so bold faith
so in that way it is you know it's a
piece you know so it's supposed to be a
little larger than life but I don't know
I'm sure there are people who kind of
operate along these line like you know
the thing about that metaphor like you
know white privilege is the kind of
thing that you just have to become aware
of and
then act accordingly in spite of or just
you know adjust yourself from yeah and
this is you know just an indulgence into
that thing and and you know on everyone
else
not everyone who responds with the white
privilege attitude though responds to a
white person a certain way his only
white though you know like sometimes
these perspectives these perceptions
that we have a natural response to
sometimes or from people who are not
white it's like the idea of I might be a
brown man but there are certain things I
have not had to deal with simply because
I am NOT a woman oh yeah
privilege I think you know like
privilege of this variety exists in a
whole lot of different areas of life and
I think that white privilege is just the
moby dick of this situation because most
all of those privileges find a
convergence point through the white and
and that's kind of you know the biggest
issue is that's why the the sis hetero
white male is the pinnacle of privilege
and so yeah I mean at the moment in just
this moment in time I feel existentially
awkward just because I'm very aware that
everything that I am is kind of what the
world doesn't need anymore of and is up
against which I'm not trying to make
this about me in any way shape or form
but just you know in the quiet moment
some days it is a little bit like it's
kind of weird to be here now because I
want to be benevolent toward the world I
want to be a credit to the force boohoo
white man see that's why I never open up
feeling either because then you'll get
because you know it's it's not a
perspective that's ultimately really I
feel like to go and dig that argument up
is like way back there or when the point
is up here you know it's it's not my
turn to grab the mic and be like what
about me because I've needed white folk
have basically been what about meeting
everything for all of time I mean I get
it it's I was watching some pitch
meeting from Ryan at Screen Rant super
easy brilliant comedian who's making
forget what it was but there's some
movie he was talking about in character
form this is two men who are producer
producer and writer right
talking about you know women taking
center stage and empowering them and
it's like yeah and it starts with us
doing would like this scenario
complication of white privilege starts
with the white man changing it like a
white man making that decision it is
like hard to find because it just seems
like we start approaching everything
with hate and attacking and that's the
work we don't know the 'some heart you
know how to go about it in a loving way
you know that's the hard part yes I
don't know because people get heated and
people care people are passionate
because these are issues of people's
lives and so it's a it creates an
fascinating situation to me because
everyone feels stuff if you're involved
in a situation and so the way people
talk it's interesting to hear pointed
back at you because I'm sure lots of
people get labeled in marginal ways and
so now the amount of times a day I hear
the words straight straight white man in
an angry voice just makes you very aware
of something and and I don't complain
too hard about it because I'm sure a lot
of other people of other cultures you
know genders identities etc have had to
deal with those things from people who
didn't care or were actively aggressive
and so yeah I don't have like a lot of
space to complain about it but it is a
strange feeling now to kind of have that
self-consciousness to walk around with
and to always be aware of when your
laces you know even though it's talked
about and there was an interesting line
here they had about the minority will be
the majority
that's unfortunate it is an interesting
line because there there seems to be a
fight for it and a stand for it I guess
the question I ponder is does it need to
be in the form though of specifically
having a take down white people
attacking and taking them down we
dismantle eve like address the issue
hardcore absolutely but do we have to
you know make all white people feel bad
because we have this belief I'm very
close to some people who really do
believe that it's flat-out impossible to
associate the word racism against white
people like it's a nuts a whole other
debate to like that
in a whole other territory right yeah
you know you got the technical level
where it's like well if you're holding
anyone's identity against them
technically you are doing that action
but at the same time you've just got
mounted context where it's like well
your well-being isn't really our concern
anymore because at least systematically
you have oppressed kind of everyone else
outside of your club so it's a shitty
behavior either way but you guys so yeah
it becomes one of those strange impasses
where there's a technical point for the
why you maybe shouldn't do that or or
why it would be considerate not to but
there's also just a whole bunch to bowl
that argument right over you know the
main thing I keep up today with is like
entertainment mediums all the time like
when it comes to like diversity in
movies well who's controlling the
decision of diversity white men usually
you are controlling that the same thing
with women in film is that a okay
supplement for now to help with the
movement you know that's the tide shift
cuz it if the white if like old white
dudes were almost of the people in power
then it has to start with the ones who
wake up and go okay well at lead very
least people who buy our stuff want this
so we will make the effort to maybe cast
more actors of or hire more directors of
color and then from there when that
starts to become more prominent then
you'll start seeing more execs of color
and exactly like what the people in
power will be more people of color and
females and stuff yeah so since all the
gatekeepers you know are of that ilk you
know it's gonna have to kind of start
with them but it really starts with the
people who raised enough Cain basically
to catch the attention and get through
to those peoples where it really it
starts at the bottom and then the big
change is happening close to the top
right what I'm thinking is we need an
all-female Ghostbusters reboot with four
white women and not let's make one of
them a black woman the things that film
did to our culture like I can't even get
excited about the new Ghostbusters
because of how ugly that was I was like
this is ruined a fandom I don't care how
beloved this movie is anymore there's no
reason we should be a BB havens
and that's a fascinating thing about
stuff like this too because the thing I
have learned to not love about social
media especially is when people discuss
relevant political topics or social
issues which you'll start to notice what
I've started to notice on either side of
the line people start to behave the same
way and that's a frustrating thing to me
because there's so much back and forth
for so little connection there is a lot
of satisfaction that can come into an
argument or debate people love to throw
Barb's and feel like they're winning -
like there's so much that gets lumped
into the way we discuss these things
that's it's tricky it's tricky you know
sometimes you got to go back to people
who help make change in the world in a
positive way that had to take a stand
had to fight for something but not
through violence
you know like I'd look flashback to like
MLK or the greatest white man of them
all by the way thanks gene for this
video this is an interesting interesting
interesting I knew this would be
something that sparked a thought - so
try not to shade
why don't you guys go ahead and
subscribe to Gene's channel he always
has things that are thought-provoking
he's like his own you know you're like
your own strange version of M night
Shyamalan who is already strange that's
what I come from your short films you
even have the video from five days ago
called my vagina so here here Oh a
strange dude who makes weird things and
I love that you just commit to it funny
so keep up with it that's what arts all
about and you got your own voice got
your own voice I was disappointed with
glass you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation notification valve and
we'll catch you on the flip that the
gods